so I have written here the formal
definition for the partial derivative of
a two variable function with respect to
X and what I want to do is build up to
the formal definition of the directional
derivative of that same function in the
direction of some vector V and you know
V with the little thing on top this will
be some vector in the input space and I
have another video on the formal
definition of the partial derivative if
you want to check that out and just to
really quickly go through here drawn
this diagram before but it's worth
drawing again you think of your input
space which is the XY plane and you
think of it you know somehow mapping
over to the real number line which is
where your output F lives and when
you're taking the partial derivative at
a point a B you're looking over here and
you say maybe that's your point some
point a B and you imagine nudging it
slightly in the x-direction and saying
hey how does that how does that
influence the function so maybe this is
where a B lands and maybe the result is
a nudge that's a little bit negative
that would be a negative partial
derivative and you think of the size of
that nudge as partial X and the size of
the resulting nudge in the output space
as partial F so the way that you read
this formal definition is you think of
this variable H you know people you
could say Delta X but H seems to be the
common variable people use you think of
it as that change in your input space
that's like nudge and you you look at
how that influences the function when
you only change the X component here you
know you're only changing the X
component with that nudge and you say
what's the change in F what's that
partial F so I'm going to write this in
a slightly different way using vector
notation instead I'm going to say you
know partial F partial X and instead of
saying the input is a B I'm going to say
it's a you know just a and then make it
clear that that's a vector and this will
be a two dimensional vector so put that
little little arrow on top to indicate
that it's a vector and if we rewrite
this definition we'd be thinking the
limit as H goes to zero of something
divided by H but that's saying now that
we're writing in terms of vector
notation is going to be F of so it's
going to be our original starting point
a
but plus what I mean up here it was
clear we could just add it to the first
component but if I'm not writing in
terms of components and they have to
think in terms of vector addition really
what I'm adding is that H times the
vector the unit vector in the X
direction and it's common to use you
know this little eye with a hat to
represent the unit vector in the X
direction so when I'm adding these it's
really the same you know this H is only
going to go to that first component and
the second component is multiplied by
zero and what we subtract off is the
value of the function at that original
input that original two dimensional
input that I'm just thinking of as a
vector here and when I write it like
this it's actually much clearer how we
might extend this idea to moving in
different directions because now all of
the information about what direction
you're moving is captured with this this
vector here what you multiply your nudge
by as you're adding the adding the input
so let's just let's just rewrite that
over here in the context of directional
derivative what you would say is that
the directional derivative in the
direction of some vector any vector of F
evaluated at a point and we'll think
about that input point as being a vector
itself a you know get rid of this guy
it's also going to be a limit and as
always with these things we think of
some not I mean always but with
derivatives you think of some variable
as going to zero and then that's going
to be on the denominator and the change
in the function that we're looking for
is going to be F evaluated at that
initial initial input vector plus H that
scaling value that little nudge of a
value multiplied by the vector whose
Direction we care about and then you
subtract off the value of F at that
original that original input so this
right here is the formal definition for
the directional derivative and you see
how it's much easier to write in vector
notation because you're thinking you're
thinking of your input as a vector and
your output as just some nudge by
something so let's take a look at what
that would feel like over here you know
instead of thinking of DX and a
a nudge purely in the x-direction no
erase these guys you would think at this
point as being a as being a vector
vector valued a so just to make clear
how it's a vector you'd be thinking of
you know it's starting at the origin and
the tip represents that point and then H
times V you know maybe V is some some
vector often you know Direction that's
neither purely X nor purely Y but when
you scale it down
you know you scale it down it'll just be
a tiny little nudge you know that's
going to be H that tiny little value
scaling your vector V so that tiny
little nudge and what you wonder is hey
what's what's the resulting nudge to the
output and the ratio between the size of
that resulting nudge to the output and
the original guy there is your
directional derivative and more
importantly as you take the limit for
that original nudge getting really
really small that's going to be your
directional derivative and you can
probably anticipate there's a way to
interpret this as the slope of a graph
that's what I'm going to talk about next
video but you actually have to be a
little bit careful because we call this
the directional derivative but notice if
you scale the value V by 2 you know if
you go over here and you start plugging
in 2 times V and seeing how that
influences things it'll be twice the
twice the change because here even if
you're scaling by the same value H it's
going to double the double the initial
nudge that you have and it's going to
double the resulting nudge out here even
though the denominator H doesn't stay
change so when you're taking the ratio
what you're considering is the the size
of your initial nudge actually might
might be influenced so some authors
they'll actually change this definition
and they'll throw a little you know
absolute value of the original vector
just to make sure that when you scale it
by something else it doesn't it doesn't
influence things and you only care about
the direction but I actually don't like
that I think there's some usefulness in
the definition as it is right here and
that there's kind of a good
interpretation to be had for when if you
double the size of your vector Y that
should double the size of your of your
derivative but I'll get to that in
following videos this right here is is
the formal definition to be thinking
about and I'll see you next video